bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 lecture le
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
de ce mercredi toujours pas de bus à
Versailles les salariés de la société
Fébus en grève depuis lundi il
poursuivent un bras de fer avec la
direction autour de leur salaire
conséquences aucun bus à Versailles aux
alentours pour les usagers eux aussi
sont en colère ce sont les membres de
l'Association des Paralysés de France
ils l'ont c'est un appel pour qu'enfin
la loi soit appliquée plus de dérogation
demande-t-il pour que les bâtiments qui
accueillent du public soit enfin
accessibles et côté européenne le Front
national était en meeting au Chesnay la
tête de liste style de français mrick
choprad présent mardi soir avec à ses
côtés Marion maréchal Le Pen
l'image du jour c'est au vélo de Rome de
Montigny le Bretonneux en ce moment et
jusqu'à 19h donc ce mercredi se déroule
la Coupe de France de l'Américaine une
compétition de cyclisme sur piste se
disputant avec des sprints et courus par
équipe de deux coureurs en catégorie
cadet junior professionnel mais aussi
amateurs a rendez-vous très
impressionnant visuellement en raison de
la vitesse mais aussi de la difficulté à
passer le relais résultat et résumé à
suivre dans notre édition de demain
ils sont en colère et le fond savoir les
salariés de Phébus société de transport
routier dont les salariés sont en grève
depuis maintenant plusieurs jours depuis
lundi il réclame notamment des
revalorisations salariales la direction
reste ferme Jérémy et brasse Vincent
Tassine
des arts vides pas de voyageurs depuis
lundi le trafic du réseau Fébus et
interrompu sur Versailles en cause une
grève massive des conducteurs qui
bloquent le dépôt les usagers prennent
leur mal en patience il y a aucun bus
donc c'est un peu galère parce que moi
je suis étudiante je suis au lycée en
fait et donc pour venir ça me prend deux
fois plus de temps parce que je dois
venir à pied je viens de
Fontenay-le-Fleury et ce matin j'ai dû
marcher depuis la gare de chantier
jusqu'au centre de Versailles du côté
des conducteurs 215 se déclarent
grévistes sur les 365 salariés contre
l'entreprise versaillesse la raison du
malaise des salaires qui n'augmentent
pas suffisamment et des conditions de
travail jugés difficiles nous avons
conditions de travail en ce moment qui
sont difficiles des temps de parcours
qui sont serrés des années ou années ils
arrêtent de ne retirer sur le temps de
parcours une rentrée si ce temps de
parcours et le temps de battements pour
l'augmentation de salaire
donc la direction nous a donné 08 en
deux fois donc on était pas d'accord sur
ça la direction a fait la sourde oreille
veulent pas avancer la direction de son
côté estime avoir tenté d'échanger avec
les grévistes pour débloquer le dépôt et
mettre en place un service minimum un
dialogue compliqué selon le directeur
moi je suis tout à fait ouvert à la
discussion avec les grévistes tout à
fait disposer à les rencontrer
dans le cadre d'une réunion
éventuellement organisée mais pour
autant et ça c'est très important que le
dépôt puisse être libéré et que les
conducteurs qui souhaitent travailler
puissent travailler parce que pour
l'instant le droit de travail de des
salariés de Phébus n'est pas n'est pas
complètement respectée le réseau Phébus
compte 26 lignes elles sont toutes
actuellement bloquées 60 000 usagers
utilisent les services de bus
on reparle comme régulièrement d'Europe
dans ce journal avec cette fois-ci le
meeting du Front national ce mardi soir
au Chesnay devant une salle comble de
plus de
350 personnes le chef de fil pour
l'Île-de-France Emeric choprade est venu
dire non à l'Union européenne telle
qu'elle existe actuellement en la
présence de la députée Marion
Maréchal-Le Pen venu appeler les
électeurs à se mobiliser Catherine
zulato Patrick Jacques de dixme
c'est une tête de liste nouvellement
engagée en politique qui se présente
pour animer la liste Front national en
Île-de-France pour les prochaines
élections européennes et Eric choprad
géopoliticien se dit nourrit de ses
réflexions et de ses expériences le
système de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas on a
aujourd'hui un bilan très clair sur le
plan économique sur le plan géopolitique
je le disais et qui fait que nous
n'avons pas construit d'Europe puissance
et qu'il y a une désindustrialisation
qu'il y a une perte de compétitivité de
la France de rang économique qui a des
problèmes d'identité il faut
reconstruire l'Europe sur des bases de
respect des souverainetés entre les
états de spécificités de chaque nation
cette nouvelle Europe a construit le
Front national ne peut le faire qu'avec
la port des voies de ces électeurs un
électorat qui reste volatile c'est la
nièce de Marine Le Pen qui bat le
rappelle nous avons un électorat qui est
dit c'est le terme des experts
sociologiquement abstentionniste on
parle en particulier des jeunes et des
classes populaires donc c'est vrai que
il y a un enjeu particulier
ceux qui pensent condamnés et la
construction européenne par l'abstention
se trompe en réalité l'abstention c'est
le blanc sain au grand mouvement en
place umpps pour ces élections le
secrétaire départemental du Front
national Philippe Chevrier candidat
également en Île-de-France a fixé ses
objectifs obtenir à 20% des suffrages
sur les 74 députés français élus au
Parlement européen 3 portent la couleur
du Front national sous l'étiquette des
non inscrits car tout l'enjeu aussi pour
le parti frontiste c'est de pouvoir
constituer un groupe au niveau européen
ce qui n'est pas le cas actuellement
eux aussi organiser leur meeting dans
les Yvelines mardi soir la formation
nouvelle donne une formation politique
lancée en novembre dernier seulement par
le conseiller régional d'Île-de-France
pierre elle la rupture ou déçue par le
Parti socialiste qu'il a d'ailleurs
quitté il se présente en tant que tête
de liste sur notre circonscription
nouvelle donne pour faire écho New Deal
de Roosevelt pour Pierre larouture ou
fondateur de ce nouveau parti il faut
aujourd'hui réviser la fiscalité réduire
le temps de travail afin de créer de
nouveaux emplois tête de liste
européenne en Île-de-France c'est le
message qu'il est venu faire passer lors
de son meeting à l'université de
Versailles
solutions il n'y a pas de baguette
magique mais si on avait en même temps
une autre politique européenne une autre
politique du logement une autre façon de
financer les PME une autre façon de
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
une autre répartition du temps de
travail tout au long de la vie si on
donnait des plus de travail au PME si on
réservé une partie des commandes
publiques pour les PME il y a 15
propositions concrètes pour montrer
qu'on peut sortir du chômage la
formation entend prendre le dessus sur
le PS aux élections un objectif
ambitieux aujourd'hui 2% des électeurs
aurait l'intention de voter pour elle je
pense que le PS est mort depuis 2002 ils
n'ont plus aucune idée neuve il y a eu
aucun moment de réflexion ils sont
arrivés là je suis allé 15 fois l'Élysée
15 fois Matignon depuis deux ans moitié
du collectif Roosevelt même la marque et
Romes ayez un an qui ne pouvait plus de
l'inertie de François Hollande sur
l'Europe même Jean-Marc Ayraud disait
qu'il ne croyait plus du tout au
discours sur la croissance je pense que
le PS il y a des gens très bien parmi
les élus locaux mais je crois
qu'intellectuellement il n'apporte plus
rien au pays et même il aggrave la crise
et les personnalités de plus en plus
nombreuses à soutenir nouvelle donne
notamment l'acteur réalisateur yvelinois
Sam Karman on a un président autiste qui
fait une politique de droite qui qui ne
se bat pas et qui nous fait croire que
toujours les mêmes rengaines il faut la
croissance et pour faire la croissance
il faut faire confiance au patronat il
faut leur faire des machins et ceux qui
ont créé de l'emploi alors on sait que
non le slogan travaillait plus pour
gagner plus c'est de la connerie voilà
c'est tout c'est organisant
organisons-nous pour partager le travail
car la croissance ne reviendra pas c'est
à partir de ce constat lucide qu'il faut
réfléchir du programme de nouvelles d'un
on retiendra à son ambition de changer
rapidement les choses 1 à 2 ans peuvent
suffire pour construire une autre Europe
selon les fondateurs du mouvement
l'Europe qui semble loin pour les
électeurs qui ne devraient pas selon les
sondages se déplacer nombreux aux urnes
le 25 mai et pourtant les décisions
prises vont directement impacter
rappelons-le encore une fois sur notre
quotidien depuis la semaine dernière
nous vous proposons de découvrir dans
une courte séquence l'Europe et vous
pour voir les implications de l'Union
sur notre quotidien ce soir cette
séquence est consacrée à la culture
Union européenne va tout simplement
apporter des financements pour des
jeunes créateurs qui souhaitent soit par
exemple créer un film ou créer une pièce
de théâtre ou créer un jeu vidéo ou par
exemple
des personnes qui souhaitent organiser
des festivals de musique ou des
festivals de films peuvent obtenir des
financements de l'Union européenne en la
matière il faut que ça ça répond au
conditions du dossier ça peut être par
exemple un festival sur une thématique
très particulière bon c'est vrai
qu'après il faut toujours ce qu'on
appelle une valeur ajoutée européenne
mais en matière de culture ça c'est pas
trop compliqué à obtenir il faut bien
comprendre que en la matière les
échanges avec les autres pays sont très
importants on imagine mal un festival de
films concentré sur une petite zone ou
sur un thème en particulier sans
forcément inviter des cinéastes
étrangers tout simplement on va déjà sur
le site internet du programme du
programme concerné parce que là on va
avoir toutes les adresses locales à qui
s'adresser lors donc généralement le
dossier est téléchargeable en ligne donc
après on le remplit on peut bien
évidemment demander l'aide à des
personnes notamment les centres-rope
direct ou qui peuvent aider dans la
constitution des dossiers une fois que
le dossier est rempli on le renvoie
directement via internet à au programme
ou à l'agence qui va gérer ce qui va
gérer ce
les personnes en situation de handicap
sont en colère l'APF a dénoncé hier
encore l'Association des Paralysés de
France les nouveaux délais accordés qui
repoussent encore un peu plus
l'obligation légale de rendre accessible
elle est bâtiments qui accueillent du
public bonsoir Liliane Morlaix et
bienvenue sur ce plateau du 7 8 lecture
responsable départemental de l'APF dans
le département nous parlions d'Europe il
y a quelques instants dans le journal et
forcément cette question où se situe la
France sur cette question
d'accessibilité par rapport à ses
voisins européens
bien à la fin bien en dernier la France
ça fonctionne beaucoup mieux
peut-être pas tout n'est peut-être pas
parfait mais en France je crois qu'on va
le record je vais repréciser les choses
la loi handicap en France date de 2004
elle devait permettre en 2015 de rendre
les bâtiments publics accessibles forcés
de constater que ce n'est pas du tout le
cas il y a encore des nouveaux délais
qui ont été accordés aujourd'hui rien
n'a été fait depuis cette loi pourtant
mais très peu il encore trop de choses
qui restent encore à faire tout est
encore à faire il y a les transports qui
ne sont pas du tout faibles et trop tôt
à la voirie n'est pas du tout fait les
bâtiments recevant du public la plupart
sont pas faits il y a des mairies où les
personnes peuvent même pas encore aller
faire leurs devoirs de citoyens c'est
pas normal c'est très discriminatoire
comment s'explique ces retards il y a
une loi elle a été votée il y a eu des
décrets d'application mais ensuite il y
a eu des délais qui ont été accordés
à chaque fois parce que ils nous disent
que c'est un coup mais bien avant déjà
qu'il y a eu les problèmes économiques
qu'il y a à l'heure actuelle on n'a pas
pour autant fait plus l'accessibilité ça
concerne l'ensemble du territoire
français on voit des images de la
mobilisation hier c'était à Paris place
de la République la place des 100 voix
puisque vous avez lancé l'appel des 100
sans témoignages à travers la France
vous étiez vous étiez présente comment
cette organisé un peu cette mobilisation
et puis depuis est-ce que vous avez eu
des retours une prise de conscience
peut-être
les gens que vous souhaitez interpeller
des politiques des politiques mais je
n'ai pas eu on n'a pas vu encore de
retour mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que on sent
quand même que les gens sont mobilisés
on a eu beaucoup de signatures qui ont
été faites sur une pétition et
heureusement parce que c'est vraiment
17000 signatures sur cette pétition
c'était les derniers chiffres
même signatures
quand on a fini la manifestation on
était déjà plus de 200 000 qui
permettrait d'obtenir rapidement cette
mise en place de l'accessibilité
lorsqu'on vous dit qu'il y a des
questions économiques qui se posent au
moment de la loi il y a des dizaine
d'années pas prévu la crise oui mais bon
à chaque fois on nous dit ça on voit
c'est depuis
1975 qu'on lutte contre ça qu'on lutte
pour avoir ce droit a été comme tout le
monde on est des citoyens comme tout le
monde je dis au moment des élections on
a tous on a toujours besoin de là on
nous appelle on nous dit on nous promet
mais après on est dans l'oubli moi je
dis que les politiques à l'heure
actuelle sont la politique de l'autruche
c'est à dire il ne voyait pas nous
entendent pas ne voient pas juste au
moment où il y a des élections là
on a on fait appel à nous mais après à
chaque fois à chaque fois on est après
on tombe dans l'oubli et ces difficultés
concrètes se retrouvent à chaque fois au
quotidien pour aller
qu'on aille ne serait-ce que d'aller
chercher notre pain qu'on aille à la
pharmacie vous trouvez admissible qu'une
pharmacie et 2 à 3 marches on peut même
pas les prendre nos médicaments et tout
est comme ça tout un cabinet médical
Vous trouvez qu'un cabinet médical c'est
normal qu'un cabinet médical il est une
marche
on peut pas tolérer ça on peut plutôt
lire on peut plus attendre on en a marre
d'où la mobilisation qui se déroulée
hier on va continuer en parler avec vous
auparavant un autre question du jour ce
micro-trottoir vous en avez l'habitude
si vous nous suivez régulièrement vous
avez la parole pour commenter
l'actualité ce soir un autre question
comprenez-vous la colère des personnes
en situation de handicap face à ses
problèmes récurrents d'accessibilité vos
réponses je trouve ça normal que ne
puisse pas avoir accès partout dans les
mêmes conditions que les non handicapés
donc ils ont raison de de ce plan et de
se battre pour arriver à avoir les mêmes
droits
et effectivement pour la circulation au
quotidien les trottoirs etc c'est loin
d'être s'éloigner adapté il y a des
petites portions qui sont adaptées mais
beaucoup on rencontre très fréquemment
des obstacles oui très certainement mais
je pense qu'on a fait beaucoup d'efforts
ces derniers temps c'est pas parfait
partout mais il y a eu pas mal d'efforts
déjà
je comprends ça évolue au rythme que la
société elle-même veut bien veut bien
lui
lui imposer donc je pense surtout que
les moyens sont différents
en fonction de la puissance de la
société et de sa volontaire réagir je
pense qu'il faut faire un effort au
niveau des collectivités collectivités
locales pardon pour financer tout ça
réaction responsable départementale de
la PM donc dans les Yvelines on a
entendu déjà des choses sont faites tout
n'est pas parfait mais ça va mieux c'est
le cas
on est loin sans éloigne encore beaucoup
trop de choses on est encore trop trop
loin de de l'accessibilité encore trop
loin
d'interpeller les collectivités locales
par exemple sur l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puisque
nous sommes à 50 ans en Yvelines est-ce
que des choses ont été faites est-ce que
c'est plus simple il y a eu quand même
une bonne amélioration qui a été faite
au sein de la voirie au sein des
transports mais c'est pas tout le reste
on n'est pas fait quoi tout le tout le
Grand Paris tout ça c'est pas fait
je le disais tout à l'heure vous avez
organisé cette mobilisation à Paris vous
étiez d'ailleurs avec nous par téléphone
pour témoigner quels sont vos attentes
aujourd'hui concrètement après cette
mobilisation est-ce que vous avez repris
de l'énergie aussi on vous retrouvant
tous ensemble oui je sens on se sent
beaucoup plus fort là on baissera pas
les bras on attendra pas on peut plus
attendre c'est plus possible là on est
vraiment je dirais qu'on est vraiment
très très en colère la colère elle se
elle se multiplie et puis on baissera
pas les bras c'est pas que d'autres
actions sont possibles encore sont déjà
prévu vous avez vous allez renouveler ce
genre d'opération
une fois de plus les images de de la
mobilisation comment ça s'est organisé
comment ça s'est déroulé qui sont ces
personnes qui sont venues témoigner et
ben les personnes qui sont venues ce
sont les représentants des départements
sans 100 personnes qui représente dans
la France dans toute la France des
délégations sont venus témoigner
pour soit pour témoigner soit pour
expliquer que la sensibilité de ce qui
vit au quotidien c'était compliqué
d'organiser une telle mobilisation si
tout un travail de longue haleine parce
que faut tout mettre en place et ça a
été c'est pas très simple surtout avec
des mobytes et réduites c'est quand même
un peu compliqué
vous avez tout ça ensemble témoigner
vous êtes représentante de l'APF dans le
département combien de personnes sont
inscrites qu'est-ce que ça représente le
handicap sur le département les
personnes du 70-8 sont entre 400 et 500
adhérents à peu près sur les Yvelines
c'est un nombre qui augmente est-ce que
justement est-ce que parfois aussi les
gens sont fatalistes et se disent
les gens
ont parfois en ont marre non ne voyait
pas le résultat et le concret on a on a
trop besoin de concret donc comme les
gens ne voient plus le concret il y en a
même qui s'en vont de la de la de
l'association parce qu'il ne voyait pas
le le l'aboutissement sont déçus on est
vraiment déçus et on est vraiment déçu
des hommes politiques et qui ne
s'intéressent jamais on entend monsieur
Valls ou Monsieur Hollande parler de
l'accessibilité il parle pas de des
personnes handicapées il n'en parle
quasiment jamais on parle de 2024 par
exemple pour mettre en conformité les
trains 2018 pour les boulangeries et
j'aimerais revenir une fois de plus pour
pour conclure sur vos difficultés une
journée type pour vous pour un
déplacement ça se passe comment et ben
une journée type ça dépend où on veut
aller mais il faut toujours qu'on
calcule faut d'abord qu'on se renseigne
si on peut rentrer dans tel magasin si
on peut rentrer si on veut aller faire
une visite médicale il faut qu'on voit
si le médecin sera accessible
il faut toujours qu'on anticipe on ne
peut pas dire comme tout le monde je
vais aller faire mes courses là je vais
on peut pas choisir on n'a pas le droit
au choix on n'a pas le droit non plus
aux loisirs parce que la plupart du
temps les loisirs ils sont accessibles
ils sont pas faits pour nous
alors on nous répond ah ben il n'y avait
pas pensé
et pour venir jusqu'ici par exemple
jusque dans les locaux de téléfils
heureusement que j'ai un transport
adapté mais qui est pas toujours c'est
pas toujours facile
donc ne serait-ce que pour venir
témoigner ce soir ça a été compliqué
merci en tout cas d'être venu et nous
livrer votre témoignage responsable
départemental de la PF la PF plus que
jamais mobilisé sur ces questions
d'accessibilité merci encore c'est la
Croix-Rouge qui nous intéresse à présent
organisme qui fête ses 150 ans 150 ans
d'action humanitaires une exposition
itinérante sur les communes de 50 ans en
Yvelines actuellement proposée Olivier
Maniscalco elodiemoine pour ce reportage
en 1914 à l'aube de la première guerre
mondiale la Croix-Rouge française c'est
qu'elle va avoir besoin de financement
exceptionnel pour récolter des fonds les
dirigeants de l'époque décident alors de
faire appel à un nouveau partenaire la
poste le premier timbre aux couleurs de
l'organisation humanitaire est né une
collection retraçant cette histoire est
aujourd'hui exposée du 12 au 16 mai à la
mairie de Montigny-le-Bretonneux une
collection permise par la passion d'un
homme une passion héréditaire j'avais
une cousine qui avait l'habitude de dire
que j'étais tombé dedans obélisque était
tombé dans dans la marmite moi j'étais
tombé dans les dans les timbres puisque
mon père était collectionneur et cette
collection de Croix-Rouge va c'est un
petit peu un petit clin d'oeil que je
lui garde puisqu'il était grand
collectionneurs de timbres de
Croix-Rouge et que j'ai remonté avec les
moyens modernes la partie terme de
Croix-Rouge de France que vous avez vu
et que vous voyez derrière moi pas moins
de 300 timbres composent aujourd'hui
cette collection parmi le portrait du
fondateur de la croix rouge Henri Dunant
ou encore une scène d'hopital ou un
blessé soigné par une infirmière de
l'association c'est un Bros symbolise
aussi la fidélité entre les deux
institutions une fidélité que la
Croix-Rouge qui fête ses 150 ans
souhaitait mettre en avant quand on
parle de 150 ans de la Croix-Rouge nous
semblait intéressant de parler d'un
partenaire qui nous est fidèle depuis
très très longtemps comme la poste et je
crois qu'il n'existe aucune autre
association qui puisse vanter d'avoir eu
ce un tel partenariat qui dure depuis
toujours en fait la collection va
continuer sa tournée dans
l'agglomération les mairies de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux trappe et mot
repas l'accueilleront respectivement
tout au long du mois de juin
dimanche 11 mai plaisir accueillait la
troisième édition du Forum africain
l'occasion de découvrir la culture
sénégalaise à travers des objets
artisanaux des livres l'intégralité et
des recettes a été renversées à une ONG
au Sénégal l'objectif est d'aider un
village à se développer au château de
plaisir le reportage de Yolaine Torres
Olivier Maniscalco et Jérémy et brasse
des colliers des serviettes des poteries
voilà ce que l'on ne pouvait découvrir
au forum africain de plaisir des
produits artisanaux confectionnés par
les habitants d'un village sénégalais
que vous avez sous les yeux c'est un
artisanat qui est fabriqué donc un DM
qui permet au villageois d'avoir une
activité en dehors de la saison de
maraîchage la saison des pluies où ils
sont au champ voilà
la famine monastère de l'humanité alors
je vous donnerai pas la réponse parce
que je l'ai pas lu
le dos
organisé par l'association Solidarité
NDM France le forum africain a deux buts
faire découvrir la culture sénégalaise
et soutenir l'ONG du village de NDM une
ONG fondée et présidée par Babacar MBO
et qui aide ce petit village à 120 km de
Dakar à se développer c'est un projet
développement multidimensionnel on
pourrait dire
il y a beaucoup de volets agriculture
bio l'agroécologie il y a aussi un pôle
santé maternité importante l'éducation
bien sûr donc des écoles qui
n'existaient pas auparavant et
maintenant nous avons beaucoup développé
ce volet
nous avons une école
maternelle une école élémentaire et même
en collège et un lycée professionnel va
représenter le prochain projet de l'ONG
de NDM le forum quant à lui a été un
succès puisqu'il a permis de récolter
près de 3000 euros des fonds qui
permettront par exemple d'acheminer des
livres d'écoles pour les jeunes de Ndem
le journal revient demain jeudi même
heure le 7 8 l'actu avec en plateau des
riverains de l'aérodrome de
Saint-Cyr-l'École toujours en colère
contre les pilotes et ses nuisances
sonores une mobilisation manifestation
et prévue à Saint-Cyr-l'École et samedi
matin dès 9h nous parlerons aussi
d'Europe et de commerce équitable la
très bonne soirée sur TV film